[Music]
in crazy rich Asian news oh I want that
to be me someday submitted by looking
good David
I thank you you're looking good I have
to how did they know good job
David looks really good in that secret
society sure to you and matching hat
thank you but they didn't fully finish
secret they misprinted in society
viewers they get cheaper if you do
that's ladders we're just gonna
scrt SCT why to get the deal secret
society it's like when they only give
you a certain amount of letters and
those like letter magnet things that a
man drove his son to school and a
Ferrari and pissed off all the parents
why because it was too loud oh yeah he's
fun huh because it was too expensive oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you
peasants I would get an even more
expensive car next time
no this is in China oh of course they're
a little bit more
don't be flashy I thought there was like
I thought there was like a million
millionaires in like just one major city
in China oh yeah and they're buying up
all the property in Los Angeles oh yeah
yeah yeah so rich people stay with rich
people but you don't do that in front of
regular people that's [ __ ] up so then
he was going to the reflects eating ice
cream in front of a homeless man and
saying I know you hungry [ __ ] and
almost guys like I can buy ice cream
they probably make more yeah right he's
like I make 30 grand a year just
panhandling bro what about you yeah so
this man the father he makes about five
hundred and seventy eight thousand
dollars a year yeah
so he drives a Ferrari 488 anything with
numbers on it at the end expensive
anything with Ferrari at the beginning
yeah yeah a Ferrari blender that would
be an expensive blender yeah even just
the Ferrari t-shirt very are they really
I got that a store the airport is that
the Ferrari store or something I don't
know but like I remember seeing it we're
in Italy and there was like a whole
Ferrari store there and I
so cool maybe I could get like a little
souvenir it's expensive $500 yeah I like
my Barbara has Ferrari Clippers
that shit's like hundreds of dollars Wow
it was got Ferrari anybody see shirt
with them I do you should buy the
t-shirt that has the ease and the a is
missing it's just for oh there you go
David
all right like Friday save some money do
my Mini Cooper [ __ ] okay so I got a Mini
Cooper and I had to buy a dongle I had
to buy a dongle so that my phone could
connect to my car so I could listen
music right and the dog was 99 [ __ ]
dollars didn't even come with it and
it's this short I mean can't even like
use your solenoid which I know they got
that [ __ ] from trying to fight coup
bucks if that
so cheaters looks crazy same color I
don't know I mean kid - cuz he's gonna
get picked on actually yeah Casey he
told me when he was growing up that
because his dad liked to have a toy car
and stuff and I sometimes would drop him
off and I always felt weird he's like no
I don't want people to see my clown
struggles you say he didn't like that
tension he's like I was trying into my
racecar bed cuz all the other kids would
be like oh is that out whatever a
Porsche or whatever and then like they
bug them all day about it yeah I mean
didn't like that tension yeah he doesn't
even like that look at that Davis coming
out of the [ __ ] public school bus
I wonder if this kid feels just as
emotionally upset as the kid that has to
come to school and a complete beater
like I wonder what the emotional like
level differences yeah I like probably
the kid and the beaters like hey dude
there's like [ __ ] 300 of us and the
beaters so yes then like the richest kid
and the poorest kid compete what about
the kid who pulls up you know those new
things that are like three wheels not
three wheels not convertible motorcycle
or something yeah it's it's a polaris
sleeves come I'd rather pull up in a car
that can barely [ __ ] run and looks
like [ __ ] then pull up in one of those
things hold that [ __ ] is fun to ride
it looks stupid but it is fun it's
always some like fad 50 year old guy
like driving it with like a sort of hot
like 46 year old lady with blonde hair
slingshot yeah yeah yeah those things
are all there oh yeah dude they are so
fun to drive it's like Joe did a bunch
of donuts in a parking lot
how'd you get to drive one so uh one of
our fans rents those out he has a yes uh
like like it's like a motorsport company
and they just ran out different things
and then he let me ride that for a day
it was pretty fun I took it to the
mountains I drifted with it I went into
a parking lot did doughnuts and dude
he's watching right now he's like you
[ __ ] it up oh no you saw the video
yeah we made a video of it
I had Pat sitting in a stand in the
middle and then I just did a doughnut
all around and I was like you said he
was shaken he was scared but it was he
was fun it was so fun it was yeah but
you're right though before that like I
would never even think of doing it
because it was like lame yeah father
here he was told by a teacher that some
parents have complained in the class
group messaging I own WeChat and so they
were saying like hey you know what how
about you just get a normal car to drop
off you're like it's that easy you're so
rich why don't you just buy another car
exactly they were just like yeah uh it
doesn't show it's not a good lesson for
all the rest of the kids it doesn't show
the value of money
next time I show up on a [ __ ] chariot
with 18 horses give me a break dude yeah
all gold chariot ooh yeah it says you
should not show they were saying you
should not show off show off no matter
how rich you are and then but she did
he'd [ __ ] drive up with his aviators
off and said What's Up [ __ ] or
or did he just drive up like a dad and
says bye yeah you know like
or ey he drives up in his aviators he
takes him off he throws mother grandma
[ __ ] it takes office Rolex breaks it in
half trucks it better a better money
lesson for the kids is that they want
the guy to bias another car just to
prove he's the same as everyone's like
no it's dropping my kids off car when
ended up happening was that this dad
refused and he was like you guys are
crazy
so he's like what's wrong with you
people so he was he was bumped off of
this chat group and then that's when a
lot of people on social media cuz they
found out about this story a lot of
people are like what like how like this
could have been a perfect opportunity
for you guys to teach a lesson to your
kids about money not not shelter them
from luxury items of the world and hide
them like what luxury items don't exist
in the real girl so yeah the parents got
back yeah and it depends on how the dad
was acting to if he just rolled up and
dropped off the kid
yeah he's living his life man if I was a
kid I would have been like wow that's a
dope record how does she get that and
then I would start thinking of like oh
cool like I want to work hard and get a
good job and do all this other [ __ ] so I
could make money like that yeah but most
people are just like oh okay now I buy
more lottery tickets let's be real your
honor man people don't think like that
yes and now the dad is like I want to
know how to get that when I grow up you
know would it like socially from like
the parents yeah I'm sure he's crying in
the fountain our bills it's lonely at
the top
he can't hang out with these peasants oh
that's where the t-shirt comes in they
don't want to see you win hell yeah I
don't want you to win oh yeah they don't
want you to win baby that's why it is I
wonder why he's taking he's sending his
kids to this school oh like he's so rich
yeah to be normal he might want them to
be normal well how are they gonna be
normal getting dropped off well like
still being around like I know non rich
people is helpful I think yeah that was
a kid who
whose parents number one Hummers were
really big yeah and you know might leave
school I went to was [ __ ] dirt poor as
it was kid he obviously was very proud
that his father had his little Hummer
you know it was like this bright yellow
[ __ ] h1 Hummer rolled up into the
school he's walking oh cool
stupid thing for him schools very ghetto
kid got beat up come on kid listen let's
not do that and I was just like we're
just all look at him like he's probably
get jumped oh damn
yeah felt bad for the guy though cuz he
had like you know the religious like
chairman thing if I can took it off his
head and everything he look at at least
they took him off his head that's yeah
it was kind of like we're all thinking
they're like man I can't believe they
did that to him runs like what did you
expect
listen ghetto at school you can't show
up so I choose a seat yeah yeah but you
see how culturally diverse we are we
have people of the Sikh religion I did
too alright we had all kinds no just
Sacramento only Sacramento dude at least
they had the respect to take off his
religious Carmen before they beat his
ass
actually why people were the minority so
disrespectful oh [ __ ]
yeah that was the big ol part Oh cuz
they're never supposed to take it off
and I thought it's like it's like taking
off your jacket so you don't get it
dirty
no like well we would have known that if
you grew up in Sacramento though true
yeah you sold me man yeah wish I grew up
in Sacramento bro
you would have been religiously
conscious alright and I only found out
after I give that [ __ ]
what's worse to know but still make fun
of it or to not know at all ignorance is
bliss well I don't know I know and I
make fun of it anyway
[Music]